[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le général de gaulle avait laissé
prévoir que le nom est venu ils
s'engageraient à feu c'est chose faite
avec son dernier discours dans lequel il
a fixé sa position sur l'algérie
l'algérie de donna quelques elle sera
décidée par l'auto détermination peut
être fait ou bien avec la france ou bien
contre la france
si cela devait être la rupture style et
bien nous nous acharnons aurions
certainement pas à vouloir rester auprès
de gens qui nous rejetterait ni
engouffré dans une entreprise sans issue
et sans espoir
nos efforts et nos milliards dans
l'emploi est tout trouvé ailleurs nous
laisserions elle-même l'algérie tout en
prenant bien entendu les mesures voulues
pour sauvegarder ce des algériens qui
voudraient rester français et d'autre
part nos intérêts mais si au contraire
comme je le crois de tout mon coeur et
de toute ma raison il s'agissait d'une
algérie où les deux communautés
musulmanes et françaises de souche
coopérerait avec les garanties voulues
alors nous fournirions à son
développement matériel et humain
les puissances et fraternel que nous
seuls pouvons lui donner
[Musique]
lorsqu'il prend son petit déjeuner au
départ du paris amsterdam
l'un des trans europe express qui
l'emportent à 140 à l'heure le voyageur
songe-t-il au chemin parcouru depuis le
paris saint-germain du siècle dernier
c'est que poursuivant son effort de
modernisation la sncf a fait sien les
deux mots d'ordre de notre temps vitesse
et confort en s'adaptant aux besoins des
usagers
l'homme d'affaires notamment grâce aux
principales relation rapide qu'elle lui
offre a aujourd'hui la possibilité de
voyager sans prendre sur son temps
[Musique]
m
c'est dans cet esprit que sur la ligne
électrifiée paris ville à la rapidité au
confort se sont ajoutés les facilités du
téléphone à tout instant un voyageur
peut ainsi entrer en communication avec
n'importe quel abonné du réseau général
et la sncf ne néglige pas pour autant
les possibilités touristiques offertes
par certains parcourent les nouveaux
autorails panoramique à traction diesel
qui roule à 120 km/heure dans des
conditions optimales de confort ont
inauguré dans les régions les plus
propices l'ère du tourisme en chemin de
fer
dans les activités quotidiennes des plus
banales le geste le plus innocent en
apparence peut avoir des conséquences
graves
des objets oubliés des sols mal
entretenues ou glissant sont
quelques-unes des raisons qui font que
chaque année en france un accident du
travail sur quatre est imputable à une
chute car il n'est pas nécessaire de
tomber de bien haut pour aller à
l'hôpital
[Musique]
autrement plus grave cependant ce sont
les chutes qui menacent ceux qui ne
travaillent pas au niveau du sol
combien de faim pas aux conséquences
douloureuses pourraient être évités si
tous les camions citernes par exemple
disposer d'une simple plateforme mais
que dire de ceux qui travaillent en
plein ciel une chute de 20 mètres
c'est avec certitude la mort ici la
moindre négligence dans le dispositif de
sécurité ou dans les conditions de
travail relève du crime ou du suicide
il importe que tous les dispositifs de
protection et en particulier les
garde-corps soit très soignés dans leur
construction et maintenus en bon état
[Applaudissements]
même s'il n'est pas mortelle un accident
sur quatre c'est trop il appartient à
chacun dans l'entreprise de participer à
la suppression des causes de chute
ne nous figeons pas aux apparences une
chute ça n'est pas forcément aussi drôle
qu'on le croit
[Musique]
l'amérique a maintenant fait son choix
mais jusqu'aux dernières heures en dépit
de tous les pronostics
la décision est resté en balance à
mickson que le président eisenhower
appuyait de tout son crédit new york a
fait dans les formes traditionnelles un
véritable triomphe
[Applaudissements]
par ailleurs à l'autre bout du continent
le leader du parti démocrate le
dynamique john kennedy que ses
supporters appellent familièrement djak
et djack y apprenait les enthousiasmes
jack contre dick dick contre jack
dernières heures d'une lutte qui fut
chaude souvent passionnées et parfois
même fertile en coups bas
[Applaudissements]
la maison blanche va donc avoir un
nouvel os et le président eisenhower se
prépare à abandonner son fauteuil le 20
janvier prochain
[Musique]
la fondation de la vocation qui a pour
objet de permettre à des jeunes gens de
suivre la route de leur choix a décerné
ses premières bourses
armand salacrou un homme de terrain et
marcel bleustein blanchet un publiciste
entre autres a remis à cette jeune fille
et 10 jeunes gens le chèque d'un million
d'anciens francs qui leur permettra de
se lancer dans la carrière à laquelle
ils se sentent appelés premier chapitre
d'une oeuvre qui peut être importante
dans la promotion sociale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à pas lents sans doute mais sur
peut-être en europe se réalise
qui eût dit naguère que des soldats
allemands viendrait manoeuvrer en france
c'est cependant le fait aujourd'hui sous
le signe de la coopération atlantique
près de 3000 noms ont débarqué avec
armes et bagages amour ne l'ont-ils
sissonne devenu pour eux au même titre
que pour nombre de français ville de
garnison
car il doit y avoir même sous le signe
de l'otan et dans le cadre des forces
européennes
une version allemande de l'ami bidasse
[Musique]
et l'on saluera comme un signe de
l'europe enfin rassemblé 7,9 et des
couleurs où s'unissent deux pavillons
[Musique]
voici les premières images d'une
naissance qui a fait à travers le monde
la joie des coeurs sensibles à la
maternité de téhéran l'enfant de farah
diba est né ce joli garçon porte le nom
de son grand père reza est celui du
fondateur de l'empiré perse cyrus
la population de téhéran à l'annoncé de
la nouvelle et a couru et le dr saleh
qui donne à ces soins à l'heureuse mère
a failli succomber sous les
félicitations
à tel point on a dû faire damner les
arroseuses pour rafraîchir un peu
l'enthousiasmé
[Musique]
au palais de westminster siège de la
démocratie britannique se sont déroulés
selon la tradition lyrique de
l'ouverture de la session parlementaire
raid ignoble façonné par plusieurs
siècles sa majesté elizabeth 2 dans
l'apparat souverain qui aujourd'hui est
unique au monde a fait son entrée
couronne en tête est accompagnée du duc
d'edimbourg en uniforme d'amiral
dans la salle des séances où était
réunie la chambre des lords et la
chambre des communes
elle a pris place sur le trône séculaire
le parlement s'est alors ouvert à
monsieur macmillan et aux membres du
gouvernement
[Musique]
session ouverte
l'angleterre continue
[Musique]
l'automobiliste parisien ne peut plus
être pressé s'ils arrivent encore à
circuler il n'est plus certain de
pouvoir s'arrêter trouver une place pour
stationner est aujourd'hui un exercice
qui tient de la ronde infernale et du
jeu de hasard
cela peut demander un quart d'heure mais
aussi bien davantage
[Musique]
c'est devant cette situation qu'on
réagit certains esprits réaliste mettant
au goût du jour l'adage populaire un bon
tiens vaut mieux que deux tu l'auras
avec la planche certains de ses esprits
malins s'assure qu'une place qu'ils
retrouveront noter que deux jerrycans
font aussi la fait voir une charrette de
charbonnier la peinture rouge du
stationnement interdit à un inconvénient
mieux vaut l'effacer pendant le
stationnement
aussi voit-on parfois lui préférer un
autre système d'interdiction le disque
parfaitement amovible est parfaitement
illégal détail curieux dans ce domaine
l'imagination ne manque pas de
ressources
[Musique]
dernier point ça n'est pas un conseil du
préfet de police
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]